mes chers amis avaient voulu la voix du
nord dans la voix du nord pour ceux qui
sont pas de la région du département il
ya martine filleul
c'est la nouvelle première secrétaire du
parti socialiste d'une heure si elle ça
change et du parrain qu'on avait
auparavant sharmarke philippe et martin
ciel qui ouvre ses universités du ps
nous dit que la région nord-pas de
calais picardie est gagnable
en fait elle est garde à bhl pour eux et
les packs gagnable le parti socialiste
aujourd'hui est tellement dans l'inconnu
avec l'inconnu n'habite pas à cette
adresse fameux candidat du parti
socialiste aux personne n'arrive à
prononcer le nom d'ailleurs personne sur
son bien
aujourd'hui madame filleul déclare que
ce candidat monsieur pierre de
saintignon
quand on lui demande comment on pourrait
qualifier ses qualités il est évident
mois le char bernard xavier bertrand
pour moi c'est un gagnant il est fort et
travaille beaucoup il est populaire il
est sérieux il a une dynamique derrière
lui mais il n'est pas évident
alors dans ce journal il ya aussi les
divisions des verts et des communistes
des socialistes et des anciens
centristes qui était pour eux parce que
maintenant ils se disent même plus
appartenir au modem alors qu'ils ont
fait leur propre majorité
mais il n'y a pas il n'ya pas madame le
pen y'a pas la fille de jean-marie le
pen
c'est vrai qu'elle est très embêté la
fille de jean-marie le pen parce
qu'entre papy qui fait la résistance au
nord et la petite blonde aux chemises
d'hoarau sud
elle a du mal à avoir enfin quelque
chose à dire à notre région nord pas de
calais picardie
elle a déclaré sa candidature la fille
de jean-marie le pen où ça à bruxelles
sur i télé bruce toussaint a dû aller à
bruxelles pour déclarer sa flamme sans
mauvais jeu de mots à la région nord pas
de calais picardie
c'est vrai qu'elle connaît bien la
région nord pas de calais picardie
mademoiselle le pen parce que
lorsqu'elle prend du château de
montretout pour aller à bruxelles le tgv
elle s'arrête à lille europe c'est un
peu dommage pour une anti européen s
pour sheikh luc et elle voit l'échangé
nord pas de calais picardie et moi j'ai
siégé quelques temps je vois brigitte
qui est ici et d'autres élus régionaux
avec madame le pen elle était bien plus
absente encore qu'à bruxelles
et quand elle suit sa rentrée politique
elle le fait à bras chez haute marne
c'est pas tout à fait dans la grande
région nord-pas képi nord pas de calais
picardie
alors si mes amis bernard gérard et mes
amis marc philippe daubresse veut bien
m'aider je propose offrir le guide du
routard du nord pas de calais à madame
le pen
pour qu'elles puissent se repérer
qu'elles puissent se repérer repérée et
qu'effectivement elle nous prenne pour
autre chose qu'un futur laboratoire pour
l'élection présidentielle alors en
quelques mots mes chers amis dans
quelques instants vous aurez la chance
de bonheur d'entendre à la fois et
xavier bertrand et nicolas sarkozy il
faut pas que vous repartiez du touquet
avec simplement cette envie que nous
étions nombreux on les a bien applaudi
et qu'on allait gagner l'élection
régionale sera extrêmement difficile
mais dans la région vous le savez bien
ça fait longtemps qu'on attend ça
d'abord on a gagné des communes
on a gagné roubaix je vois monsieur le
maire de roubaix le maire de roubaix
notre famille politique
guillaume delbar et là nous avons gagné
la deuxième ville de la région
on a gagné tourcoing la troisième ville
de la région
notre ami et collègue maire d'amiens udi
a gagné la deuxième ville de la région
nord pas de calais et picardie lent mais
amiens
on n'a pas encore gagné l'île mais on va
s'en occuper on arrive on arrive nous
avons gagné quatre départements sur cinq
alors que tout le monde lui disait que
dans l'aisne notamment dans la somme
et pourquoi pas dans le nord ou pourquoi
pas dans l'oise le front national est
faire des scores gigantesque nous avons
gagné quatre départements sur cinq avec
le plus grand département du nord qui
depuis 1992 a toujours été à gauche jean
rené lecerf qu'on peut également
applaudir à gagner le plus grand
département du nord on a empêché à
madame aubry de rester président de la
communauté urbaine de lille
rien que pour ça ça valait le coup eh
bien les 6 et 13 décembre
on gagnera la région nord pas de calais
picardie alors je vous donnais juste un
petit argument à vos amis qui vous
demande pourquoi il faut aller voter ou
qui en ont marre ou qui veulent aller
voter pour la partie extrême et 10
droite et gauche c'est pareil
et ben moi je suis né en 1982 à
valenciennes dans la région j'ai fait
mes études dans la région j'ai travaillé
dans ma région je suis maire d'une
commune de la région
jamais la région nord pas de calais n'a
été à droite
jamais jamais nous avons connu quelqu'un
qui économiquement allait pousser notre
région alors tout à l'heure bernard
gérard hardy au travail c'est le slogan
de xavier il promet pas grand chose
d'autre que du courage que du labeur que
du travail il y aura peut-être des
larmes dissipe 6 6 et 13 décembre
mais si vous mobiliser par le 13
décembre ce sera une grande fête
non seulement pour nous mais pour le
pays tout entier merci beaucoup